I was hoping there'd be a strong
indictment I'm not as Trump supporter I
voted against them and it would
vindicate the American legal system and
the New York Criminal Justice System but
the D.A has labored and has produced a
mouse it's an extremely weak indictment
the basic theory behind the indictment
is that once Trump paid 130 000 in hush
money to prevent his family his wife his
business partners from learning about an
alleged adulterous Affair he should
immediately have then made it public in
his corporate forms no one in the
history of the world has ever done that
and yet the district attorney really
expected that of him we've had thousands
of hush payments made starting with
Alexander Hamilton early in our history
and up through Uh current corporate
leaders nobody in history is ever then
disclosed it on a corporate form and
that yet that lies at the center of this
um this frivolous indictment against him